welcome to Calvin lands I'm Sara
Underwood I'm a former TV host and I'm a
model and I'm Jacob whistling I am a
second grade teacher I built cabins and
I'm almost as famous as Sarah for the
next two years we're gonna be living on
this amazing piece of property in the
Pacific Northwest building cabinets but
before we get into all of that let's
catch you all up first met because
cabins were blowing up on Instagram and
I really wanted to get some shots at
them so I messaged him right into my
dams I slid into his dunes and asked if
I could come shoot his cabins I said
yeah okay when I got there he
immediately took me on a walk around the
property I mean he must have listed off
like 20 different ferns look at
desperate I wish it up all five that I
know George Burns
dear burn licorice burn made in fern it
sounds like a lot cuz I say fern each
time it was that night that we realized
that we had the same dream of building a
bunch of cabins on a piece of property
and homesteading in the rainforest oh I
love it
imagine walking I've heard of people
getting married after like six months we
were like oh yeah
little cabin I can't believe you did it
we're doing it it's happening a little
bit we're gonna build eight to ten
magical cabins on this 15 acre beautiful
piece of land that we just bought I feel
like I'm in Legend of Zelda and our
friends and our family are gonna be
coming along to help us out I know but
it's gonna be mostly us slugging stuff
back through the woods one wheelbarrow
load at a time back-breaking work
we don't have roads through this
property we have to call each piece of
lumber every tool back to the cabin
I'm putting all my money into this and
she quit his job but something in us
told us that we wanted to do this and we
just went for it
Gary what we're doing is totally batshit
crazy
we don't really know exactly what's
gonna happen except that we're gonna
build some epic cabins and they're gonna
be in the middle of the gorgeous
rainforest and we're gonna document the
whole entire thing and share it with as
many people as can stomach it psycho
geometry what we're gonna show everyone
on this channel is homesteading and
learning how to homestead
what Sara go from someone who has
limited experience to someone who has a
great deal of experience you're gonna
see Frank each other I don't think
people want to see that okay you're
gonna see him dancing is that okay see
me sing musicals that I've been singing
since the seventh grade so please
understand you're gonna see us working
and living in the elements I mean we're
in a rain for you're gonna see rain lots
of rain you're gonna see the rain and
moss and mud go to cabinet land so
you're gonna see this idea that we
bonded over when we first met actually
come to life and be captain lands
after cabin rain
I feel like the town crier up here cabin
line come one come all come in line
let's have a ball from near and far from
far in there come to cabin land my dear
please be sure to LIKE and subscribe
this channel so you never miss an update
and please back us on patreon so we can
keep these free videos coming yes free
ain't free we need you back us please